STEPHANIE WONG: Hey, everyone.
This is Stephanie Wong,
Cloud Developer Advocate.
And today, I am
really, really excited,
because we have our Google
Fellow here, Eric Brewer.
He has been here helping to
build Google and Google Cloud's
infrastructure over
the last like decade.
And we are so honored
to have him here today.
So Eric, thank you so
much for being here.
How are you today?
ERIC BREWER: I am
fantastic, hanging out
in wonderful Marin
County, enjoying
being remote for today.
STEPHANIE WONG: Same here.
I am just a stone's
throw away from you.
But I do want to jump
into it right away.
I was actually able
to dig up this tweet
that you had a while ago.
I think it was
about 10 years ago.
And you were talking
about your initial plan
to help build infrastructure
here at Google
and how much work
there was left to do.
So what was that initial
plan, and how did it pan out?
ERIC BREWER: Well, that
was based on my thinking
really from the '90s.
So before VMs were
a big deal, I was
working on what
you would now call
cloud computing at UC Berkeley.
And it was really
based on a model
that used a lot of processes,
and services, and APIs.
And I still like
that model better.
So when I got to
Google, I kind of
felt like we need
a new cloud that's
a higher level of abstraction.
And of course, that led to
Kubernetes and all the things
we do in the modern
version of that.
STEPHANIE WONG: What's it like
to see that come to fruition
and have the industry
adopt it over time?
ERIC BREWER: It's
incredibly exciting.
Even when you plan
something-- like, oh,
we should do a new orchestration
layer based on containers,
because it's more like how we
think the cloud should work,
it's more like how
Google works internally--
that's fine to say that.
But then you have to
create the projects.
And you have to decide
to open source them.
You have to get
fellow travelers,
as I say, other groups that
want to bet on this journey.
And of course, you
need to get adoption.
And all that happened.
And after maybe eight years
working on Kubernetes,
it's in a remarkable place.
STEPHANIE WONG: And it's
taken quite some time for us
to get to where we are today.
I'm curious, what
was it like to be
one of the first and biggest
supporters of Kubernetes,
working on it from
a very early stage?
Were there any
unexpected challenges
that you underwent in
implementing it across Google
and also across the industry?
ERIC BREWER: Well, I think
there were two obvious hurdles
internally.
The first was we already
had App Engine and VMs.
Why do we need a third
way to do computing?
And so there's some natural
resistance to change.
And the answer is
because the third way is
better than either one alone.
And the second one is,
this is such a big deal.
Why would we open source it?
And we didn't tend to do
much open sourcing of systems
things, as we do now.
That's a bit of
change in philosophy.
But for Kubernetes,
I just felt it
was too big a change
for the industry for us
to do it by ourselves,
and open source
was an important part of
getting the fellow travelers
that we needed.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yes.
Yes, and it's had quite an
impact, as we know today.
But tell me a little bit
more about the open source
ecosystem, what
it's grown to be,
and what it's looking like
over the next 10 years.
Is the cloud going to
continue to change?
Are we moving towards more
higher level of abstractions
or opinionated surfaces?
ERIC BREWER: Well,
yes, yes, and yes.
So Kubernetes is about, I think,
the second-largest open-source
project now behind Linux,
which makes a lot of sense
and is an achievement in itself.
But really, it's because
it's now the cloud platform,
or the enterprise platform.
And the reason for that
is it's both versatile--
you can do many things
with it-- but also,
that it's easier to operate than
just the raw VMs or raw disks.
And so it's a good
platform to build on.
But again, I think
it's better viewed
as a platform for platforms.
If you say, well, I
really like Cloud Run.
It's easier to use
than Kubernetes--
that is absolutely true.
Cloud Run is not as general
purpose as Kubernetes.
So the way I think
about that is,
I want many opinionated things
that are vertically oriented
on top of Kubernetes.
Kubernetes is great for
building those things,
both inside the
enterprise and out.
And in the end,
the collection will
be Kubernetes becomes less
visible, because you're
using the things on top of
it in your daily experience
with your future cloud.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yes.
And what I love
about the cloud space
is that it's all about
providing both developer
freedom and flexibility,
but also empowering
them to have that optionality
for these opinionated services.
They want cloud
providers to give them
the best-of-breed
security, for example.
ERIC BREWER: Yes.
It's actually good
that there are
many functions as a service
built on top of Kubernetes.
And some will be great.
Some will be less great.
But the fact that
there's many of them
is actually a good
thing for everybody.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
Now, OK, you've done 10
years of this type of work.
It's changed at a speed that
I'm sure nobody had expected.
But what are you hoping to
achieve over the next 10 years?
Anything that you might
predict will be the next wave
or fundamental shift?
Or is it really
hard to say based
on your experience so far?
ERIC BREWER: Well,
I think one big one
that we're in the
middle of is how
to combine the philosophy
you can get from something
like Kubernetes and CI/CD
with the security we clearly
need as a nation, and in
general, for all nations.
And so a classic view
of security is to say,
oh, I don't want
to change anything.
There might be vulnerabilities.
But it turns out it's
the exact opposite.
If you really want
to be secure, you
have to be able to update
your software quickly,
because there are latent
security problems that
will be discovered and you'll
then need to fix them quickly.
And so my biggest
focus at the moment
is really around open-source
security, the supply chains
and its security, and
how to really make
that a much more opinionated
stretch, from source code
to actual deployment,
having better metadata,
better control of all those
steps, better attestations,
which can make proof statements
about those deliverables.
And so you'll understand
what your real risks are,
and of course, minimize as
many attack points as possible.
And that is going to
be a big change, also.
STEPHANIE WONG: Well,
that is a perfect tee up,
because in our next video
that we're doing together,
we are going to be talking more
about how you have been helping
to build a better security
process for software supply
chains and how trusted software
providers are the future.
So thank you so much, Eric.
Everyone else, stay tuned.
We are going to keep these
conversations coming at you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]